[Music]
can you imagine
what a world without prisons would look
like
happier safer scarier
or is it just impossible to imagine
maybe that's because it feels as if
prisons have just
always been part of society even though
they haven't
the idea that prison can reform and
rehabilitate
is only around 200 years old
[Music]
or perhaps it's because we're told we
need prisons to deter criminals
even though there's no consistent link
between the prison population
and levels of crime or is it because we
think
prisons keep us safe for some offenders
their time in prison
can be a period of reflection and growth
but others struggle
and can become traumatized or more
dangerous and reoffending rates
are high
[Applause]
but just because it's hard to imagine
and we don't have all the answers yet
that mustn't stop us trying to consider
a world without prisons
and asking ourselves if there is a
better approach
a world without prisons would mean
upending our current system
and putting the needs of those who are
harmed first
right now prisoners are too often used
as a kind of last resort
for dealing with the inequalities and
problems that our health
welfare education and employment systems
aren't solving
which is one reason why people from some
ethnic minorities
from poorer communities those with a
history of mental health problems
or people who have grown up in care are
all more likely
to end up in prison crime won't be
reduced by continuing to lock all these
people up
what will help is tackling the societal
problems that have led them to commit
harm in the first place
so in a world without prisons funding
priorities would need to shift
using some of the current prisons budget
might help
but this would just be a small
contribution in fact
far bigger and systemic change is needed
because while we focus on blaming
prosecuting and punishing the harms and
crimes of the poor
all too often we ignore the wider
economic structural
and psychological harms committed by the
powerful a world without prisons would
be fairer
but could it also be safer
[Music]
yes a small number of people do need to
be kept out of society for the safety of
us all
but although the idea of evil looms
large in our culture
our prisons content fewer dangerous
people than we imagine
nevertheless any attempt to reduce
danger and harm in society
would need a new culture of safety and
respect
ensuring those who may be harmed are
properly protected
and preventing violence in the first
place rather than allowing it to breed
in prisons and return into
communities properly funded
interventions to safeguard vulnerable
children from harm
and refuges for victims of sexual or
domestic violence
would be essential and how would victims
feel in this world without prisons
wouldn't they want well justice to be
done
in fact most victims don't cite revenge
or punishment as their priority
what they care about most is protecting
themselves and others from harm in the
future
restorative justice or a truth and
reconciliation process
is a very effective way of doing this
allowing victims to talk through
grievances
accept what has happened to them and
rebuild their lives
the impact of any harm is formally
recognized by the one who caused it
but also by society this encourages
communities to take responsibility for
helping both victim and offender
because when you can't simply lock
someone up everyone
has a vested interest in finding ways to
live more peaceably together
in a world without prisons justice isn't
about punishment
it isn't about repeating cycles of
violence and harm
it's a world where justice is about
writing systemic wrongs
about supporting people to meet their
employment education and health needs
it's a world focused on social justice
rather than vengeance
so a different approach isn't impossible
but maybe
many of us are still imprisoned by old
ideas
imagining a world without prisons will
require all of us
to think outside the box